corrupt institutions which were
enriching people's private interests
called up their buddies in DC or their
dad and said this guy is getting in the
way to 10 for the big guy so we've got
Tony bobulinski this is one of the under
Biden Associates saying out right he's
in on it you've got the emails 10
percent held by by what does it say HB
for the big guys is that what it said
was that was that barismo or is that the
China thing 10 for the big guy I think
was a China deal my point specifically
though is we can see in these business
dealings there is evidence that Joe
Biden is personally benefiting we also
have the text from Hunter Biden where he
said something the fact of dad taking
his salary or things like that so he's
acting as a proxy for Joe Biden while
Joe Biden was in government Joe Biden
personally goes and gets the prosecutor
fired who was investigating the company
where his son was getting 83 000 a month
there it is Devin Archer testified
before Congress